faces okay
so the first one i'm going to do is kind
of very small
come up
this place
and just like anything he's going to
take a chemi okay
so i'll go slower but don't take the
candy
all right i'm not going to sit here and
take it in his stomach
okay
he wants to train to be responsive at
the same time he's not cowardly
so he's not no
he jakey can be means to reconcile yin
and yang so he has to receive the young
energy before he goes yet
so when he's cowardly it is he did not
receive the young energy
that would be a counter
in kihon laws that we don't do
encounters okay
train according to your uk once you get
it
you're going to add the key on
[Music]
stay connected the whole time
okay uh
again
a basic fighting concept is you attack
what's closest to you
[Music]
so that's not closest to me
sansar
don't attack the weapon another basic
concept
is
a roman maxim
fight the archer
not the arrow
okay
so
in the atosh
your first attack
is twofold
the hands and because we're doing aikido
whenever i touch from where i touch goes
into his center
when you go into his center you attack
his mobility that attacks his ability to
counter
got it so
this would not be a dead
that's finding the arrow
and then bypassing hands and center
secondly
your art
is of a particular nature
it's going to repeat patterns in the
universe
so you're going to come up
and not move this out of the way
it's going to come up
and i'm going to go around it
here
so i'm not an alternate universe where i
come over here
around the weapon
and i'm not clashing with the weapon
so the first move comes up
and then begins around it
making this different
and making this different
you're going to see it come up
and go around it
this way i already made connection with
the weapon and now whatever camry does
right i can stay connected to the weapon
over here it leads to aiuchi
right
and this doesn't do what you think it's
going to do it just pushes his sword
around into king
i hid it there
you see that not he he
he did the same thing to me and got it
around i hid it around his head okay
so that's kind of like the three stooges
thing knock my hammer face down
okay
kind of down
so
up and around contact came down
contact
down
we're going to mell out the final thrust
okay let's see the rotating cross
and the center drop
for the otoshi okay
okay uh
i am attacking his hands
but i'm not attacking the center by
pushing straight down on his hands until
it pulls on his shoulders and then it
starts to affect his
center so i'm not i'm not doing
something like this
okay
so here's his arm i'm not gonna
push it down until i get his shoulders
and then i get his center
it's from where i'm touching i'm in in
the center
so i want i want from where i'm touched
again it's not that i take his arm
and then that's what i pull it and it
makes the center move backwards from
where i'm touching i make his center i
want his center to go that way
i want his center to go this way
right so when i wanted to go down it is
going to go from here into the center
you see that okay so same thing here
this is not going here
this way it goes in
you see that
so not here
because i'm going to want to ski past
that you got it so as i as i add the ski
into it
and that's what takes it into this ski
okay
on the ski though
get in a steep position okay
and let's look at how you
where you got there so unwind the film
got it
okay
and
go ahead and push me do that same no
just rewind that's it
push me
good
push me go harder
good and your heart is
good
and your hardest
what did you feel
that one had a lot more resistance on it
where did okay so let's let's do it
again so you i want you to go hard your
hardest
okay
and again
okay what happened to your body
got pushed it's getting pushed back do
you see that so i'll demonstrate this
again
um
let's do it another way
let's
have you go here
you see where you are
okay and then you go
his arms are about there arms back there
and he's gonna bring his arms in
okay and then
he's gonna do what he did
you see
so imagine i'm running at him boom
it's not gonna do what you think it's
gonna do
same thing here again he's here
okay and you would say
oh it would have been a killing blow it
would have been a killing blow
so he's going to do it his hearts
i kind of look okay then you go well it
wasn't deep enough
you were you were standing at the edge
of it
okay so here
let's watch actually go rewind it and
zoom do
okay
what is going on
well again if you look at
bayonet fighting
they're not like this
it's in your body
like uh
like joust
you don't throw the weapon
you hold it to your body
and your body moves
you see that my body moves
that
part comes
after the inertia is taken and he's gone
that way
so it can't be
[Music]
that's not gonna work
it's gonna hit
here
body
boom and
then in okay
again
people started imagining
[Music]
lightsaber spheres
and you can
do that kind of stuff okay
but
let's not imagine things
so spoken
i will show it
i want you to watch the timing when i
make contact
it's in this position when i first touch
his body
okay
it's not in this position when i touch
his body okay so i'm going to do the
technique
you see and that is what would roll over
got it okay
let's try the whole thing now
so
moving on a little too cute guys
i'm doing the same thing
so where he felt that attack on his
hands is he did the rotating cross back
to me so i'll show you okay but we're
going to go slow there's the
beginning of the rotating cross
and he wait he's going to feel the drop
that's why he rotates across again and
this drops into empty space
see that
so he's not letting this
i'm not doing that
but he's not going early either
he is reconciling the dong energy with
the same rotating cross
that means his sword will hit me
in the middle of my technique and he's
got a chance now as opposed to i go
no that's never gonna get that off okay
so again another marshall rule we
already did one hit the thing that's
next to you we did two fight the archer
not the arrow and now three
his counter must be in the midst of my
attack otherwise it does not work okay
so he has to wait boom that's what he
gets
all right let's try okay
okay so i'm going to feel that i'm going
to feel that
you're going to feel the void do you see
that okay so i'm going to feel the
rotating cross
um so we go a little slower so as as i
start to go and he reconciles that i'm
gonna keep that contact
because i'm always following the in
energy
got it
okay so as i go here i'm gonna keep that
here
and then i always follow the thread
so i didn't do anything with my sword
but stayed stuck to hit with my joke but
stay stuck to his weapon and he peeled
it off in his attempt to cut my head
okay so whoa
and now i have to uh obey the mind of my
weapon so you see another word i'm not
going here
next martial concept
dominate the center line
make him
have to work around it that will give me
the martial initiative he has to deal
with me
okay
so
keeping all these things in mind when i
go i have the center line again
you see
so my body my orientation
is here
it's from there that when it comes down
we're going to do it in stages again
it's embryonic so this is not the timing
of machiatosh this is the vectors of
material
okay
so it's going to look like this
embryonic that's what i mean by
embryonic it's not the timing of
machiatush it's the vectors of
machiatosh so at a certain point
his weapon stops being a sword and now
becomes a kind of guide for my uh
technique okay
so it comes around
now it's gonna be a guide
okay
i'm gonna have another rotating cross
and i'm going to go around there and
attack the hands and the center again
boom that's the guy
again not just his hands
from his hands
into his center
okay from here
i have my skin
this isn't it
back
and
only hit
through
so even without the follow through
you're going to see
it's doing the displacing okay
let's try it